so you want a girlfriend but she's got
to be hot brainy and she's got to have
balls well that's what guy wants it's
one of the reasons he moved to Israel
you're in the Middle East you grow up
with conflicts you grow up with people
around you saying that we want an aisle
eight you want it we want to destroy
Israel one that we want to kill the Jews
I know the world thinks that Israeli
women although the arm and they all have
guns they all shoot and all my officers
okay women all your officers were women
when I went to the army
I had nine-year-old little tiny girls
screaming at me fire don't fire do this
do that do this all that kind of stuff
do you like that yeah you mean in terms
of that yeah did you like to do of
course I mean okay
I'm still human being I mean i yeah i'm
still a male here two guys look like two
guys one day young me redhead two
guys looking for a wife who cares about
Judaism as much as he does once back in
the US where he grew up
he thought he'd met his dream girl wrote
I don't know I don't know Halle sherry
at South attend Bahama but I tonight
with heckled by myself Leona but she was
Catholic looking back he says it's
better the relationship didn't work out
6:30 a.m. time to get a move on
now you'd think that moving to Israel
the only majority Jewish country in the
world would make it easier to find a
nice Jewish girl especially if your type
is Israelis but dating kind of sucks no
matter where you are and living like guy
sure as hell doesn't help so you're
ready for work I mean right it's not a
clock already it's late
you know sooo tired yeah four hours
asleep of the night is normal
do you think you're busy well guy runs
three nonprofits and a biotech startup
if you're working this much how much
time do you have to actually go out and
meet people because it seems you've got
this pitch tomorrow got a fundraiser
coming up for a completely different
organization than a third organization
you're looking to hire someone when are
you gonna find this girl hence the hence
the reason why I am not getting anyone I
haven't any one for a long time and why
I need a matchmaker that helped me is
because I yeah it's been it's been a big
problem can't you just walk up to people
and meet them no not not really I mean
you you can but there's there's a limit
right so for instance like there's a
girl over there there's a girl over
there there are few girls I've never
there's one rule specifically which I
noticed I think she's beautiful there
was one I want at the corner all the way
at the the one just raised her hand but
the gone yeah and the blonde she she's
really pretty
okay I don't wanna be like another notch
on her belt which is another guy that
she gets to to real lightly reading the
last three women guy dated all broke it
off with him because they said he didn't
make enough time for them he says the
right girl will understand he's just
busy I'm wondering if a dating
professional might see things
differently okay when was the last time
that you had like a day a five-hour
block of time on one day I'm talking
about a weekend not a weekday where you
could spend we could turn off all
technology and just be focused on that
girl on a weekend yeah
oh I don't remember the last time that I
had five hours straight things can be a
little bit messy they don't have to be
in drawers and in boxes you know she can
come with you to a friend's birthday
party she can come with you to an event
and she I think it's okay yes once after
like a month I think and and she knows
you're your lifestyle so this is the
gallery
this is SHINee the one that doesn't have
time to come to Tel Aviv until the
evening she was a model but she's a
lawyer
but I think she's stunning yes stunning
I think but she lives out of town still
jessica has 40 other women in her
database and one of them's already on
her way
I'm a little nervous I can't restrain
dimensionizer oh there she is - I
brought you this is guy time Shalom hi
Finnish man no it's a bi-metal I was a
little nervous for him too but it turns
out guys really good at this how about
specifically grilling me as dark as a
shoe okay as I need I'll be she left you
last time this time first times Alba Wow
yeah the devaluation the hunger the
descent on the phone alone damn new date
number one seems pretty successful but
guy still wants to see who else jessica
has up her sleeve guy named on Russian
bat like a solana a camellia revolta
yeah okay Mona as more advanced over my
motto Tommy stole my shoe
the Saregama who lie it was a smoothie I
can - sorry bro I've made the father
honey it's okay masala don't know and me
my piety honey shucks shut up
is it oh [ __ ] well guys showing off his
small talk skills I'm gonna hit the
beach to work on my sunburn now you
should probably know like guy I'm Jewish
and American but for me finding a Jewish
partner obviously isn't a priority since
I chose to move to Germany it is
important though to many of the tens of
thousands of people who moved to Israel
each year the given operations as they
possible make emerge real videos of us
leafy from the infamous River over $1
Papa would you date a non Jew it would
be a lot of trouble to my family in I
have a very good repent relationship
with them so he will need to be very
worth it can I just have yeah that's oh
my god you guys are working hard out
here trying to figure out the meaning of
love do you think for the Jewish people
to survive we need to be a little bit
more open to loving other people and to
letting people who want to be Jewish
because they think Judaism is cool be
Jewish
this sunset over the Mediterranean means
the beginning of Shabbat a bunch of guys
friends are coming over for dinner to
celebrate the Jewish Sabbath it's
supposed to be a day of rest the things
here are a little hectic as usual Oh
give me two minutes
around the table our young Jewish people
from four different continents but it's
not just all their nationalities that
make this scene impressive I'm
surrounded by couples gay and straight
and Tel Aviv a city where people say
finding a partner is next to impossible
there's some basic math involved the
more options you have the harder it is
to commit because you never know who's
just around the corner at Adonai nml how
long I've mostly left him in hot
man Oh God oh that one I knew it just
rub it off intro to people it's finding
love really just about being lucky
meeting the right person or do we have
to change ourselves our schedules and
our expectations to make love happen
what do what do you think our is
conditions that are making this harder
well it's really difficult to find like
an incredibly like model beautiful very
smart talented like driven woman that
like also wants to wait like five or
seven years to have kids you know like
when you put all those things together
it's uh anyone supposed to be with you
yes and loves guy I've never heard of
any six like real success stories for
people who like made like finding a wife
or finding a husband like their number
one priority you're doing some amateur
matchmaking already for guy always I
mean like I'm a Jewish woman like I just
don't know how to not it comes in your
nature you just do it automatically if
he likes a girl he immediately like
wants to do what every can of her that
and then he just like puts himself
riding the friendzone and they like
can't think about going on a date with
them um so I tried to coach him out of
that
now guy said he really enjoyed both the
dates the matchmaker set him up on but
he just couldn't stop thinking about
SHINee that stunning model lawyer he
didn't meet yet
how're you feeling I'm tired for a long
day but just when I'm actually really
excited for I'm not gonna lightly this
one saw the profile it looks like the
girl that would be sitting at a cafe
that I would want to go talk to and I
wouldn't go talk to and now I get set up
on it so it's nice and I have to put so
much energy into a girl that I think is
probably more for me together that when
I checked in with guy a few weeks ago he
said that both he and SHINee had been
too busy to meet up again no big
surprise there I guess but something
must have happened because guy says this
one date completely changed his approach
since SHINee he's been going for the
girls he used to think we're out of his
league and it turns out it's going
pretty well sometimes things that seem
crazy are just crazy enough to work
you